what I am searching for why I am
searching for is something like this
sign or that I want this for any value
of theta right so it made it could be 2x
or it could be x times pi or it could be
epsilon 2 or whatever okay the important
things is that I want the same thing in
both spots okay so when you have a look
at this it's written it's deliberately
written form to see can you see past the
weakness of it and get to where you need
to go okay so what does the limit look
like well you can see the sign term is
gonna be on the numerator and this is
gonna be on the denominator
usually that doesn't really matter okay
put in this question know what to divide
it x it does matter so I'm gonna rewrite
it like this sine of X on 2 pi divided
by X does that make sense so you can see
ya all right there's my theta
it's defined it's x over 2 pi I have no
other choice for what this is going to
be I need to change the denominator to
reflect that okay so if I'm gonna say
okay
let's change this denominator so it's
not X but it's excellent soup I what I
need to multiply by is 1 over 2 pi do
you agree with that on the denominator
okay
now if I had some fraction like 1 over X
and I said okay well if I put it to
there then in order to keep the fraction
the same fraction I'm gonna have to
multiply by 2 at the front right so if I
had to multiply by any number like say
alpha then it's going to appear both
times does that make sense
now what I've multiplied by it is a
fraction so therefore the same fraction
is gonna have to appear at the front
does that make sense so this is not 2 pi
here because that's a to file in denoted
it's not a chip I'm in denial it's a 1
over 2 pi on the denominator so to
compensate the exact same number comes
out front just like it did here so now
I've got my 1 on 2 pi
what does this become
so there is money now people gotten
confused by this it's not complicated